ja liebe userinnen und user wir gehen
direkt nach berlin zur pk von angela
merkel und den vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zu den
neuen corona maßnahmen wie auch schon in
den letzten tagen ein beschluss
vorbereitet
ausgangspunkt und notwendigkeit ergibt
sich daraus dass die maßnahmen die wir
am 2 november begonnen hatten nicht
gereicht haben nachdem wir eine zeit
lang das exponentielle wachstum stoppen
konnten und eine seitwärtsbewegung hatte
haben wir seit einigen tagen wieder
steigende fallzahlen und ein
exponentielles wachstum und das bedeutet
dass hier auch sehr viele tote zu
beklagen haben sie verfolgen die
statistik ja alle und wir wissen dass
auch das gesundheitssystem schon sehr
stark belastet ist und unser auftrag
oder unser vorhaben war ja immer eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems zu
vermeiden
deshalb besteht dringender
handlungsbedarf und daraus resultieren
die beschlüsse die heute gefasst wurden
ziel bleibt das will ich hier noch
einmal unterstreichen dass die kontakt
nachverfolgung wieder möglich wird das
heißt wir brauchen instanzen von 50
fällen pro 100.000 einwohner in sieben
tagen und geringer
das alles hat natürlich auswirkungen auf
die feiertage das wissen wir
aber wir sind zum handeln gezwungen und
handeln jetzt auch wir haben miteinander
beschlossen dass die ordnung der länder
bis zum 10
januar gelten werden also dann erst
einmal aber das ziel bleibt eben
die inzidenz runterzubringen das heißt
wie es anfang januar weitergeht können
wir heute noch nicht sagen sondern hängt
dann von den ergebnissen ab die wir
erreichen
wir bleiben bei den persönlichen
kontakten dabei dass freunde verwandte
und bekannte sich treffen können mit
maximal fünf personen und zwei haus
ständen und es gibt nur über die
weihnachtstage vom 24 26
dezember davon eine ausnahme nicht aber
zu silvester und neujahr
diese ausnahme heißt dass man über den
eigenen hausstand hinaus noch vier
weitere personen einladen kann
und zwar aus dem engsten familienkreis
also ehegatten lebenspartner partner
oder verwandte der geraden geliebt linie
das sind eltern und geschwister eltern
und kinder sowie auch für geschwister
gilt das aber es wird an alle
bürgerinnen und bürger appelliert wenn
sie andere haus stände aus der familie
zu weihnachten zu sich einladen wann
immer möglich die kontakte sieben tage
vorher zu reduzieren also eine schutz
woche einzulegen
so lässt auch neuer also die normalen
kontakt beschränkungen keine
sonderregeln wir werden ab mittwoch ab
dem 16 dezember in einzelhandel
schließen und nur noch für lebensmittel
und ähnliche dringende waren des
täglichen bedarfs offen halten es wird
auch darauf geachtet dass der verkauf
von nicht lebensmittelprodukten im
lebensmitteleinzelhandel nicht
ausgeweitet wird und es gibt ein verbot
des verkaufs von pyrotechnik vor
silvester das wird vom
bundesinnenministerium per verordnung
sichergestellt es müssen auch schließen
die dienstleistungsbetriebe im bereich
der körperpflege die zb friseure und an
den schulen sollen die kontakte deutlich
eingeschränkt werden ebenso bei den
kindertagesstätten in das bedeutet dass
kinder wann immer möglich zu hause
betreut werden
und daher werden im zeitraum ab 16
dezember also ab mittwoch die schulen
grundsätzlich geschlossen oder die
präsenzpflicht ausgesetzt es würden
notfallbetreuung bereitgestellt und es
werden regelungen zum distanz lehren
lernen angeboten für abschlussklassen
können gesonderte regelungen erlassen
werden
kindertagesstätten wie gesagt analog zur
schule wo immer möglich sollen die
kinder zu hause betreut werden
es werden die arbeitgeberinnen und
arbeitgeber gebeten betriebsferien oder
großzügige home office lösungen
anzubieten vom 16 dezember bis 10 10
januar
und was die frage von mitnahme fähigen
speisen für den platziert zu hause durch
gastronomiebetriebe anbelangt so bleibt
das weiter möglich aber der verzehr vor
ort wird untersagt sie wissen dass wir
in den letzten tagen und wochen eine sie
wissen dass wir in den letzten tagen und
wochen immer wieder eine situation
hatten in der doch sich ansammlung von
menschen vor einrichtungen ergeben haben
wohl der verzehr möglich war
gottesdienste sind nur unter engen
voraussetzungen möglich wir werden dazu
gespräche mit den kirchen führen
das wird das bundesinnenministerium
machen
eine besondere beachtung finden die
alten und pflegeheime sowie mobile
pflegedienste hier soll eine
verpflichtende testung mehrmals pro
woche angeboten werden
wir raten von reisen ins im innern und
ausland die nicht zwingend notwendig
sind ab und die quarantäne regeln werden
dort so weitergeführt wie sie heute sind
es wird umfangreiche wirtschaftshilfe
geben dazu wird der bundesfinanzminister
etwas sagen und wir haben damit ein
umfassendes maßnahmepaket verabredet
dass natürlich die lebenssituation
vieler menschen war einfluss und das
dazu führt dass die kontakte stark
reduziert werden
und deshalb möchte ich den menschen in
deutschland danken dafür dass sie in
einer großen zahl bislang die regelungen
eingehalten haben und möchte alle ganz
eindringlich bitten auch in den nächsten
tagen von kontakten die nicht unbedingt
notwendig sind abstand zu nehmen und
damit einen beitrag zu leisten dass
unser gesundheitssystem nicht
überfordert wird und ich möchte vor
allen dingen gehen die in den
krankenhäusern arbeiten den ärzten den
schwestern pflegern in den altenheimen
ein ganz herzliches dankeschön sagen für
die sie wird dies ein sehr schweres
weihnachten und unsere beschlüsse sind
deshalb dringend geboten um gerade sie
auch zu unterstützen und menschen mehr
gesundheitliche sicherheit zu geben
herzlichen dank ja es hat in den letzten
tagen einen sehr detaillierten aber auch
einen sehr schnellen und
einvernehmlichen abstimmungsprozess
gegeben zwischen den ländern und
zwischen dem bund und den ländern
und tatsächlich wie die bundeskanzlerin
sagt das sind jetzt einschneidende
maßnahmen für eigentlich alle
beteiligten einschneidende maßnahmen für
die familien natürlich für schülerinnen
und schüler für die einzelhändler für
viele unternehmen für die kultur die
nach wie vor noch keine perspektive
haben wie es weitergeht
es ist ein wirklich umfassender
beschluss auf den wir uns hier
verständigt haben
ich möchte gerne noch mal für mich auch
die ganze situation einordnen und
darstellen das aus meiner sicht auch in
den letzten monaten schon alles passiert
ist weil ich das immer wieder ja gerade
in den letzten tagen auch gelesen habe
warum erst jetzt warum nicht noch weiter
gehen warum nicht härter warum kann sich
die politik auf dieses oder jenes nicht
verständigen
wenn man sich das anguckt was seit
februar märz passiert das und zwar in
allen bundesländern muss man sagen wir
haben sehr schnell und entschlossen
gehandelt und zwar alle
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
dinge eingeschränkt und geschlossen von
einem tag auf den anderen dinge die
vorher selbstverständlich waren waren
dann eben nicht mehr möglich und wir
haben in einer in einem großen einigkeit
immer wieder im grundsatz uns auf
weitere schritte verständigt natürlich
an den hass an regionale maße
gegebenheiten es ist ein unterschied
zwischen großen flächenländern auch in
grenzsituationen oder stadtstaaten es
ist ein unterschied zwischen ländern mit
sehr hohen und ländern mit sehr
niedrigen inzidenz und wir mussten und
haben immer wieder auch ein weg
gemeinsam weg formulieren können und
haben vielen menschen helfen können
sowohl was den gesundheitsschutz
anbelangt als eben auch in bezug auf auf
perspektive wieder auch wirtschaftliche
perspektive oder für die
kulturinstitutionen wieder dinge möglich
gemacht das war und ist uns doch auch
allen wichtig nach wie vor auch immer
dort wo es möglich ist wieder normalität
zuzulassen und deutlich zu machen dinge
gehen auch aber wir haben eben an dann
auch wieder an den situationen wo wir
gemerkt haben dass die zahlen sich
leider wieder nach oben entwickeln
sofort wieder nachgesteuert im oktober
im november im dezember und warum dann
nicht sofort harter lockdown ich will da
auch an das frühjahr mal erinnern wo
viele auch zu recht gesagt haben wir
haben doch gelernt aus dem frühjahr
manche dinge gehen auch nicht von heute
auf morgen so wie jetzt zb im bereich
kita und schule
familien müssen auch die chance haben
sich wenigstens ein zwei tage auf die
situation einzustellen
etwas zu organisieren für die kinder die
schulen müssen die chance haben
wenigstens ein zwei tage
diese digitalen angebote dann auch
umzusetzen an die familien zu vermitteln
die einzelnen waren eine einzelhändler
die gerechnet haben mit einem
weihnachtsgeschäft müssen doch die
chance am 1 2 tage auf diese situation
auch zu reagieren und wir haben immer
wieder auch gelernt durch beratung durch
erfahrungen die wir gemacht haben im
zusammenhang mit der pandemie bekämpfung
auch wissenschaftliche beratung hat sich
verändert in den letzten monaten in
bezug auf kinder auf schule in bezug auf
die pflegeeinrichtung und und und alles
das ist immer wieder eingeflossen auch
in uns
beschlüsse und insofern sage ich auch
man kann über jede einzelne maßnahme vor
und runter diskutieren warum so und
nicht anders warum heute und nicht schon
gestern
oder warum erst morgen aber im
gesamtbild es ist glaube ich sehr
wichtig auch dass wir deutschlandweit zu
einem zu einer guten verständigung
kommen zwischen den ländern und dass wir
maßnahmen auch gemeinsam tragen über die
letzten monate und das ist immer wieder
auch gelungen und auch jetzt ja das ist
richtig wir haben viele dinge auch
berücksichtigt und hoch und runter
diskutiert so wie es in ihm dargestellt
habe unterschiedlichste erwartungen
wurden natürlich auch formuliert aus den
unterschiedlichsten perspektiven aber
ich will es für mich auch wieder ganz
klar sagen letztendlich bleibt der
maßstab der gesundheitsschutz der
gesundheitsschutz ist das a und o wie
können wir bestmöglich menschen schützen
und wir haben und perspektiven auch
durch die impfungen in nächster zeit
umgesetzt werden können die uns allen
auch glaube ich große hoffnung geben
dass wir wieder erneut ein stück
normalität uns erarbeiten und erkämpfen
können auch mit diesem impfschutz
aber es wird noch dauern es wird noch
dauern bis dann wirklich viele geschützt
sind durch die entsprechenden impfungen
und das bedeutet wir müssen weiter
achtsam sein und wir müssen weiter eben
auch durch einschränkungen menschen
schützen wir müssen weiter kontakte
vermeiden und in dieser kontakt
vermeidung spielt jetzt irgend alles
eine rolle auch wenn wir nicht besondere
auffälligkeiten an den schulen haben
gibt es dort kontakte im umfeld der
schule und gibt es infektionen und auch
wenn einzelhändler und handwerker
natürlich die maßnahmen alle gut
umsetzen und auf regeln achten gibt es
kontakte und über die kontakte gibt es
erneute infektionen und wir sind einfach
im moment in einer situation wieder wo
wir alles was nur irgendwie möglich ist
auch einschränken müssen um diese
kontakte und damit neue infektionsketten
zu vermeiden
und insofern würde ich mich auch dem
abschließenden appell der
bundeskanzlerin noch einmal anschließen
ja es sind dinge natürlich auch
weiterhin möglich es sind dinge im
zusammenhang mit weihnachten und
silvester möglich aber man muss auch
nicht alles machen was möglich ist
sondern man muss sich jetzt auch selbst
prüfen wie man am besten sich selbst die
eigene familie freunde und verwandte
auch schützen kann und das sind
einerseits die regeln und das ist zum
anderen eben auch tatsächlich die
kontakt vermeidung im größtmöglichen
umfang und es ist nicht in jeder
lebenssituation und jeden tag immer
umfassend möglich aber es ist mit
sicherheit für uns alle möglich auch an
dieser stelle noch mehr zu tun als
bisher
um uns eben auch gemeinsam zu schützen
bis der impfstoff uns allen entsprechend
helfen kann
also insofern glaube ich dass wir bei
allen zumutungen dies jetzt auch wieder
gibt für so viele menschen in unserem
land dass wir hier einen sehr
verantwortungsvollen weg auch
miteinander formuliert haben und das ist
auch meine dringende bitte das den alle
mittragen und uns in unseren bemühungen
unterstützen
wir haben eine sehr verehrten damen und
herren liebe mitbürger mitbürger des hat
keine normale ministerin konferenz
musiker letzten vier fünf monate haben
wo wir stundenlang geredet haben wir
kleine details heute ist die lage anders
denn corona ist außer kontrolle geraten
die lage ist eigentlich wieder fünf vor
zwölf deswegen wollen wir keine halben
sachen mehr machen sondern konsequent
handeln wir hatten letzte woche in
bayern den katastrophenfall ausgerufen
und ein journalist fragte mich ist das
nicht übertrieben und natürlich davon
dass es da sehr viele praktische fragen
geht kroner ist eine katastrophe krone
ist eine katastrophe die unser leben
mehr betrifft als jede krise die wir den
letzten 50 jahren zu worden
das sind braucht es jetzt auch eine
kraftanstrengung von uns allen eine
nationale kraftanstrengung ganz oder gar
nicht heißt das motto nicht mehr halt
hat sich ein bisschen oder versuchen
ausnahmen und schlupflöcher zu suchen
sondern konsequent entscheiden
der lock down leicht wie wir versucht
haben
hatte eine wirkung er war eine medizin
aber sie hat nicht gereicht
wir waren nicht mit der notwendigen
therapie konsequenz dabei wenn wir nicht
aufpassen wird deutschland schnell das
sorgenkind in ganz europa deswegen
mussten und müssen wir handeln
besonders schlimm und besorgt macht uns
doch alle von die zahl der todesfälle
alle drei minuten stirbt jemand in
deutschland an corona es wird wohl die
dritthäufigste todesursache in diesem
jahr werden das sind können wir darauf
nicht achselzuckend reagieren oder das
als statistische größe wahrnehmen wieder
all den stecken familien menschen die
auch gerne weihnachten silvester lebt
hätten die kliniken echt sind die
echtzeit derzeit unter der belastung
teilweise gibt es schon trias in
deutschland nämlich dass man entscheidet
wer behandelt wird oder wer woanders
sind verlegt werden muss wir reden
manchmal über ferien und einzel details
oder was einkaufen
dabei kämpfen pflegerinnen und pfleger
und ärzte jeden tag eine schier
unermüdlichen kampf bergamo ist näher
als der ein oder andere glaubt um das zu
verhindern müssen wir konsequent handeln
wie es sind nicht herzlos genau das
gegenteil ist der fall
mich persönlich und wir uns alle rührte
und deswegen dürfen wir aus
bequemlichkeit oder einen monetären
interessen keine fehlentscheidungen
treffen denn eines lehrt uns überall
kronen der welt je länger man je später
man handelt desto länger dauert es und
desto größer sind die schädigung für
gesundheit und wirtschaft das positive
heute ist wir haben alle miteinander
klar und konsequent uns auf einen
beschluss geeinigt kein sowohl-als-auch
sondern eine richtung ist eine bittere
pille aber ich glaube diese dosis ist
jetzt richtig gewichtiges wir machen
nicht wieder eine diskussion über
ausnahmen sondern über konsequentes
umsetzen
sind wir ehrlich seit monaten haben uns
die diskussion über ausnahmen und
details und das letzte haar in der suppe
letztlich auch die akzeptanz vieler
dieser gemeinsamen ideen geschwächt und
untergraben
deswegen ist wichtig ab mittwoch richtig
lockdown in deutschland
für alle konsequent und auch klar
verständlich und anwendbar geplant bis
der januar ich sage ausdrücklich so
lange es dauert krone hält sich nicht an
daten der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
corona hält sich nicht an feiertage
coroner nimmt den freiraum dem beben
lässt und deswegen ist unsere oberste
aufgaben priorität jetzt das virus zu
bekämpfen
es hat überhaupt keinen sinn überall in
der welt gibt es zweite und dritte
wählen sogar übrigens in der geschichte
war immer die zweite oder dritte welle
am gefährlichsten haben die zweite warum
weil man es unterschätzt hat das ist
doch heute wichtig noch einmal klar zu
machen dass wir in einer sehr ernsten
situation wird es ist zeit für
gemeinsamkeit der alles sitzt in
deutschland im gleichen tot
alle müssen mitmachen und deswegen aus
meiner sicht war das halt sehr sehr
wichtig die gute vorbereitung die klare
führung auch durch die kanzlerin wenn
ich das sagen darf und auch dass alle
mitgemacht haben wir bayern sind
besonders betroffen
wir haben erstmals sind sie denn es
werde über 200 für das ganze land
überschritten
das heißt wenn man es aufs land zieht
sind wir ein hotspot aber es ist anders
als bislang gedacht in den letzten
wochen war die tendenz
es wird im norden weniger und im süden
hoffentlich auch ein bisschen weniger
ist jetzt umgekehrt von süd nach nord
wandert es überall es geht ganz schnell
es ist auch keine frage von besser oder
schlechter sondern nur von gemeinsam und
gleich betroffen wie wir agieren müssen
für bayern kann ich sagen wir werden die
beschlüsse maximal umsetzen wir haben in
der letzten woche bereits ja maßnahmen
vor getroffen die alle in diese richtung
gehen und bin sehr dankbar dass wir
diesen weg gemeinsam gehen können was
heißt jetzt komplett lockdown alle
geschäfte zu ab mittwoch es gab in einer
anderen der dass auch er hätte gern
machen müssen das lag aber nicht daran
dass wir jetzt mittwoch haben weil ein
ministerpräsident nicht wollte sondern
weil es klare parlamentsbeteiligung und
gibt die dazu zwingen fristen
einzuhalten deswegen am mittwoch das ist
insofern auch dann ein besonderes
vorgehen weil wir damit auch uns an die
eigenen gesetze halten die vorgegeben
es gibt dafür eine umfangreiche
entschädigung des bundes auch dafür
schon mal ein herzliches dankeschön in
den innenstädten also alles runter bis
auf die geschäfte sage mal dass
lebensmittel und es wirklich
notwendigsten alltäglichen bedarfs
denn die philosophie heißt daheim
bleiben die philosophie heißt kontakte
vermeiden
die philosophie heißt nicht irgendwo
sein sondern am besten zu hause mit der
familie deswegen übrigens auch in den
innenstädten nicht nur geschäfte zu
sondern auch ein klares alkoholverbot um
glühwein zu go und lieber ein hopping zu
verhindern
zweiter ab mittwoch für bayerns
eigentlich dass alle schulen und alle
kitas komplett zu eine klare regelung
es ist so dass vor weihnachten damit wir
kein risiko eingehen wir wollen
studien zeigen zu nehmen dass auch
kinder auch kleinkinder betroffen sein
können meist ohne jedes symptom aber
dafür umso leichter die möglichkeit der
ansteckung weil wenn kein symptom ist
man vielleicht eher zum sozialverhalten
darauf weniger rücksicht nehmen zu
können und die kleinen nehmen wir auch
besonders gerne in den arm das ist bei
17 18 jährigen sicherlich etwas anders
neue studien usa oder österreich zeigen
dass dort ein erhöhtes risiko ist
deswegen vor weihnachten auf nummer
sicher gehen und wenn dann richtig wohl
nicht wieder ihr da halb oder damit
deswegen ab mittwoch alles zu alle
jahrgangsstufen und feiern mit distanz
unterricht ja mit notbetreuung das gilt
für schule und kita
dort wo es notwendig ist für die eltern
mit ausgleich eltern können auch ein
ausgleich nehmen wenn es keine
möglichkeit der betreuung gibt und sie
deswegen urlaub nehmen müssen dann soll
es einen finanziellen ausgleich geben
und appell an die arbeitgeber
das glaube ich sowieso wichtig sowohl
über weihnachten neujahr so möglichst
viel betriebsferien zu machen und im
home office anzubieten wo es nur geht
diese maßnahmen gelten alle auch in der
schule
bis 10 januar während bayern haben den
vorteil dass wir zu vier länder gehören
die ohnehin bis 10 4 januar zusammen es
gibt uns zeit aber auch danach kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen dass einfach alles
wieder so normal weitergeht worauf wir
allerdings besonders achten dass
abschlussklassen ihre prüfungen schaffen
werden darauf wird geachtet entweder
durch das verschieben der
prüfungstermine wir holen das so nach
ohne zusätzliche leistungsdruck
die schülern schülern eltern sollen sich
darauf verlassen können wir werden alles
tun dass die gleiche bildungsqualität
erhalten bleibt ohne ein zusätzliches
stressabbau oder eine stress mittlere
reife oder abschlüsse zu haben
zu den privaten kontakten da bleibt es
zunächst einmal bei den bisherigen
regelungen für uns in bayern ist das
eine klare ausgangs beschränkung die es
gibt das haus triftigen grund zu
verlassen
wir haben in bayern schon in den
bisherigen über 200 aus ganz starren
gemacht von 21 uhr bis 5 bundesrats in
den letzten tagen sehr bewährt wir
halten daran fest und wir werden nach
den bayern jetzt überall im ganzen land
200 hat werden wir das jetzt für ganz
bayern machen warum wir wollen auch da
die ganzen privaten feiern private
kontakte einfach reduziert ich weiß das
ist nicht einfach und es ist gerade für
die jungen leute unglaublich nervig und
stressig aber jetzt lieber für die
nächsten wochen wieder zusammen halten
als das ganze eine endlosschleife zu
haben es hilft uns nichts wir müssen
ganz besonders an die älteren denken zu
eltern und großeltern sie zu schützen
ist gebot für uns alle bei weihnachten
gibt es eine verbessere regierung die
kanzler hat es schon gesagt dort war es
besonders schwierig seien auch die
gottesdienste ja für viele ist das eine
große einschränkung dass gottesdienste
nur mit maske mit anmeldung um abstände
zu halten und ohne gesamt stattfinden
soll
aber trat in der kirche geht es um das
leben der menschen in schutz der
menschen
wir sind glaube ich ist es gut
vertretbar an silvester die klare
regelung dort wo ausgangssperren sind
gilt es auch übrigens dann ist ab 21 uhr
das ist bei uns dann in bayern so bleibt
man ohnehin zu hause
da geht es auch die gesamten anderen
regeln wir haben uns wollte noch mal
darauf verständigt dass die facto
paperport zu haben
warum jetzt die faktoren der tod hat ihn
das böllern irgendeine auswirkung
pandemisch zunächst auf den ersten blick
nicht wir haben aber den krankenhäusern
den dringenden wunsch bekommen den
dringenden wunsch dass wenn die normalen
verletzungen die es jedes jahr ein
böller gibt dazu kommen sind die
krankenhäuser nicht mehr aufnahmefähig
deswegen in diesem jahr eine ausnahme
das heißt es wird halt ein stilles
silvester es ist schade es ist wirklich
schade aber es ist glaube ich in diesem
jahr gebaut
bei alten und pflegeheimen ist uns der
schutz der älteren ganz besonders
wichtig sei übrigens gezeigt obwohl seit
monaten alle länder und kommunen hier
entsprechende schutzmaßnahmen treffen
ist krone reingekommen
übrigens nicht nur durch besucher
sondern eben auch durch durch
mitarbeiterin mitarbeiter
das hat mir den grenzregionen übrigens
auch gespürt dass dort einträge möglich
sind es hat letzte woche in der
fernsehsendung auch das
max-planck-institut übrigens noch mal de
facto mit bestätigt haben wir klare
regeln besucher nur einmal pro tag mit
maske mit test test pflicht für
mitarbeiter mindestens zweimal die woche
und das sage hier zu bayern wo es nur
geht auch vorhandene andere
einrichtungen zu nutzen um eine
entsprechende verlegung zu machen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren das sind
jetzt klare regeln ich glaube dass sie
auch weil sie für alle sind und ohne
große ausnahmen sind verständlicher und
besser kommunizieren mit machbar sind
wir haben in den vergangenen monaten
mehr regelwerke die selbst da eine
andere minister wenn er gefragt vor dem
fernsehen
erst mal nachschauen musste ob er sie
alle parat hatte das kann man jetzt
glaube ich ganz gut verstehen
für manche ist es eine große
einschränkung enttäuschung ich bin
sicher dass es für die mehrzahl aber
eine gewisse erleichterung ist weil sie
froh darüber sind dass wir jetzt alle
den einheitlichen weg gehen
es fällt uns nicht leicht es zu tun
betont es nicht wie manche der
querdenker gruppen meinen aus einem
politischen motiv im sinnes würde uns
freude machen wir tun ist nicht weil wir
es wollen sondern weil wir es müssen und
zwar aus echter verantwortung für die
menschen für eltern und großeltern und
für das ganze land
es gibt hoffnung natürlich auch in
dieser schweren zeit die maßnahmen jetzt
in hoffnung bei dir fest überzeugt sind
sie können wirken wenn alle mitmachen
wir kommen da auch durch als deutschland
wir überstehen das auch die frage ist
nur mit welchen schäden und wir wollen
sie so klein wie möglich halten
der impfstoff ist eine hoffnung ja auch
wenn das sicherlich nicht über nacht
geht erst der anzeigen sind ja da das
nicht alles an impfstoff zur verfügung
steht wie
gewünscht das heißt sie müssen sehr klug
überlegen wie wir trotzdem konsequent
impfung könne die logistische
infrastruktur in ländern steht in bayern
fast 105 zentren über 2000 ärzte die
bereit sind mich selber davon nicht so
überzeugt entspannt war bei uns die
woche da und es läuft sehr gut aber erst
muss der impfstoff da sein da muss noch
mehr klasse und wer alles gibst werden
kann
das wird noch gar nicht einfach werden
ich sage ihnen aber auch meine
hauptsorge ist nicht das am impfstoff
vom anzug zu wenig ist sondern am ende
sich nicht genügend werden es wird nicht
reichen nur die wohl darauf in gruppen
zu müssen
nur die risikogruppen nur die kritische
infrastruktur sondern es müssen alle
auch beim impfen mitmachen denn sonst
wird es ein ständiges hin und her auf
und ab und das ist doch die perspektive
die wir brauchen
irgendwann einmal den großen wurf zu
machen so dass wir mit möglichst viel
schutz durch impfungen und niedrigsten
zahlen die wir haben auch deswegen
übrigens fürs impfen brauchen wir
niedrige zahlen keine roten zahlen
das zu schaffen insofern schließe mich
aber dem appell an das kommt jetzt auch
wirklich jeden einzelnen an keiner steht
außen vor
bitte ganz herzlich mitzumachen es ist
eine schwierige zeit aber vielleicht ist
die sogenannte startet zeit bahn sind
bayern wenn man sagt zwischen
weihnachten neujahr die jetzt sozusagen
früher beginnt und länger dauert ist
vielleicht die beste gelegenheit daheim
zu bleiben und ein ist noch mein letzter
satz zu besinnen
das wichtigste geschenk an weihnachten
ist nicht das teuerste sondern ist die
zeit die gemeinsam verbracht werden kann
in der familie und auch das sollte man
dieses jahr vielleicht mal viel stärker
als je wieder bewerten und bis hin
vielen dank herr chance biete wir würden
heute sicherlich gerne zum dritten
advent weniger schwierige botschaften
mitteilen aber ich glaube ganz fest dass
das die zeit des sind der ist notwendig
ist das zu tun was unsere aufgabe ist
wir haben als regierung geschworen
schaden vom deutschen volk abzuwenden
und genau darum geht es wenn jetzt diese
entscheidung getroffen werden
das glaube ich muss auch jeder wissen
das virus macht keine ferien das virus
feiert keine stille weihnacht
sondern es darauf angewiesen dass
menschen sich begegnen in großer zahl
und dass es dann von mensch zu mensch
übertragen werden kann
deshalb muss es jetzt darum gehen dass
wir angesichts der gestiegenen
infektionszahlen und der prognosen die
wir für die weitere zeit haben weitere
entschiedene klare kontakt
beschränkungen gibt die auf die
verschiedenen weisen in deutschland
durchgesetzt werden dass wir diese
situation gut vorbereitet haben ist ein
beweis dafür dass der deutsche
föderalismus und die art und weise wie
wir regieren auch ordentlich
funktioniert bin sehr froh dass wir die
ganze woche über stunden lang
miteinander gesprochen haben
um vorzubereiten dass heute eine
schnelle und zügige entscheidung
getroffen werden kann
denn aus meiner sicht wäre es nicht gut
gewesen wenn angesichts der bedeutung
dieser entscheidung und der
weitreichenden konsequenzen die damit
verbunden sind wir jetzt tatsächlich
heute den ganzen tag über commerce und
andere fragen diskutiert hätten hier
geht es nicht um kommerz es geht um
gesundheit es geht um das leben der
bürgerinnen und bürger und
dementsprechend muss das auch gut
vorbereitet und dann schnell umgesetzt
werden dass wir gemeinsam handeln ist
auch ein zeichen dafür dass es gut
abgewogene und die richtigen
entscheidungen sind das glaube ich kann
man ganz ausdrücklich den bürgern und
bürgern unseres landes sagen es sind
entscheidungen bei dem sich niemand
irgend ein einziges detail leicht
gemacht hat aber es sind welche über die
alle einigkeit haben
deshalb glaube ich kann man gut davon
ausgehen dass es entscheidung sind die
helfen werden und die auch jetzt
erforderlich sind
dass wir die kontakte beschränken dass
jetzt der einzelhandel im außerhalb des
täglichen bedarfs eingeschränkt wird das
sich auch in schulen und kitas die
kontakte reduziert werden wobei wir sehr
darauf geachtet haben dass niemand
nachteile in seinem schulerfolg hat und
die schulabschluss erreicht werden
können das alles sind richtige und
notwendige maßnahmen
sie haben aber auch konsequenzen um die
wir uns kümmern müssen und für die wir
uns verantwortlich fühlen
und deshalb ist mit diesem beschluss und
auch mit den maßnahmen die wir zur
förderung der wirtschaft auf den weg
bringen auch verbunden dass wir allen
beistehen die hilfe beistand und
unterstützung brauchen
ich will dass im hinblick auf die
situation zum beispiel der gewerbe
mieter und pächter in den städten
deutschlands sagen sie haben jetzt eine
situation in der sie sicherlich mit
ihren vermietern und verpächter neue
über die vertragsbeziehungen dieser
situation reden können müssen wir werden
sie dabei unterstützen
wir werden all die steuerlichen
erleichterungen die wir bei
verschiedener gelegenheit gemacht hatten
alle unter gesetzlich möglich nutzbar
machen dazu gehören auch
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten für wangen
die aktien verkauft werden können dass
sie schnell und unbürokratisch genutzt
werden können und vor allem aber wird es
eine sehr umfassende wirtschaftshilfen
überbrückungshilfe geben
wir haben von anfang an die unternehmen
in deutschland nicht alleine gelassen
mit den ersten maßnahmen zur
stabilisierung der deutschen wirtschaft
auch während des lüftens dann mit den
überbrückungshilfen danach gegenwärtig
sind wir noch bei der zweiten und
überbrückungshilfe und wir haben schon
lange vorbereitet die daran
anschließende bis zum sommer des
nächsten jahres gelten der
überbrückungshilfe 3 das zeigt wir sind
bei ständiger weiterentwicklung unseres
förder und hilfe regimes angelangt wir
greifen immer wieder neue erkenntnisse
und anforderungen auf und wir haben
natürlich auch ganz besonders die
jetzige situation im blick wenn wir den
unternehmen und geschäften helfen die
jetzt von den schliessungsentscheid
betroffen sind
es wird bis zu 500.000 euro
unterstützung im monat geben für direkt
oder indirekt geschlossene betriebe wir
werden mit der überbrückungshilfe weiter
auch all denjenigen helfen die indirekt
betroffen sind weil sie zwar nicht
geschlossen sind aber von den geringeren
handelsgeschehen auch berührt sind in
dem wir leichter möglich machen dass man
bei umsatz ein ausfällen von bis zu 40
prozent dann auch die überbrückungshilfe
in anspruch nehmen kann
die da bis zu 200.000 euro
tragen kann und wir geben dann jeweils
entsprechend der größe des umsatz
ausfalles unterstützung bis zu 90
prozent der fixkosten die anfallen
können
mittlerweile haben wir viele regelungen
getroffen wie zb besondere situation
berücksichtigen dass die
veranstaltungswirtschaft was die kinos
betrifft oder zum beispiel was
aufwendungen von unternehmen betrifft
die abschreibung haben für mit krediten
finanzierte anlagen das alles ist gut
berücksichtigt und wird unterstützung
leisten
wir werden das auch für das nächste jahr
so machen wenn dort schließung sind wir
das auch dazu führen dass diese
überbrückungshilfen zur verfügung stehen
um ihnen ein gefühl zu geben für den
umfang der maßnahmen die hierzu auf den
weg gebracht werden und genutzt werden
können wenn es zu an der vollen
schließung für einen ganzen monat kommt
rechnen wir mit ausgaben knapp über 11
milliarden euro für einen monat und das
zeigt das ist schon eine sehr umfassend
gestaltete unterstützung ich will
gleichzeitig sagen ich halte sie für
absolut richtig
denn es geht hier um existenzen es geht
um männer und frauen die über viele
jahre und jahrzehnte sich ein geschäft
aufgebaut haben und die jetzt sorge
haben dass in wenigen wochen und monaten
eine ganze lebensleistung vor ihren
händen vor ihren augen verschwindet das
muss aufgehalten werden mit den
möglichkeiten die wir haben und
natürlich geht es auch um die vielen
arbeitnehmern und arbeitnehmer die in
all diesen betrieben beschäftigt sind
lassen sie mich zum schluss noch mal
sagen es kommt unbedingt auf uns alle an
jeder von uns seinen beitrag leisten
dass wir die bürgerinnen bürger schützen
können indem wir die regeln einhalten
die wir miteinander aufgestellt haben
was abstand und hygiene betrifft indem
wir die zahl der kontakte reduzieren so
weit es möglich ist und in dem wir damit
die gesundheit unserer liebsten unserer
freunde aber auch viele andere
oldenburger die wir nicht kennen die uns
wichtig sind und von denen wir wollen
dass sie jetzt nicht von dieser
gesundheitskrise schaden
das wird die unterstützen wir kommen
dann jetzt zu ihren fragen die erste
frage hat herr blank dpa
frau bundeskanzlerin dass eine blitz mpk
mit sehr weitreichenden weihnachts
notbremsen sozusagen was haben sie getan
dass die ministerpräsidenten jetzt so
schnell und so umfassend sich haben
einigen können und sind das nicht die
dinge die sich schon vor wochen hätten
vorstellen können um mehr leben zu
retten und weniger tote zu haben und an
die ministerpräsidenten hat denn die
kanzlerin jetzt mit ihrem vorsichtigen
kurs recht behalten im rückblick können
sie das sagen und es gibt ja schon
stimmen die sagen der föderalismus ist
jetzt stärker an die grenzen gestoßen da
sagt der brinkhaus auch da muss man sich
gedanken darüber machen wie sehen sie
das als ministerpräsidenten und eine
frage bitte an herrn scholz diese
bezahlten urlaubstagen wie viel können
dass sein danke so ich wollte zu beginn
sagen falls nachher recherchen
angestellt werden welchen zettel ich
weiter gegeben habe an herrn brücher es
war die bitte die unterrichtung der
fraktionsvorsitzenden aus 12 uhr 15 zu
verschieben damit wir noch ein bisschen
zeit für fragen haben so damit es auch
der umfang dieser pressekonferenz
definiert jetzt hat herr blank er gleich
eine vielzahl von fragen gestellt dazu
will ich folgendes sagen es heute
wirklich nicht der tag jetzt zurück zu
blicken oder irgendwie zu fragen was
wäre gewesen wenn
sondern es ist der tag das notwendige zu
tun das haben wir miteinander
beschlossen das haben wir gut
vorbereitet und jetzt ist es notwendig
ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass die
leichteren maßnahmen eine bessere
wirkung entfaltet hätten wir haben ja
hier gesessen und haben gesagt wir
brauchen 70 prozent oder 75 prozent
kontakt reduzierung werden in den besten
fällen nur 40 prozent
und jetzt gerade auch durch das einkaufs
geschehen zu weihnachten das ist die
zahl der kontakte noch mal stark
angestiegen das heißt wir müssen jetzt
diese maßnahmen treffen sie haben eine
breite wirkung auf viele viele menschen
uns ist das bewusst aber sie werden auch
eine wirkung haben damit unser
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
und das erfordert jetzt allerdings alle
anstrengungen und eben auch diese
schnelle handeln und deshalb finde ich
heute sehr einverstanden mit den
maßnahmen die wir getroffen haben wir
haben ein großer ernsthaftigkeit in den
letzten beiden tagen drei tagen das
miteinander vorbereitet und das zeigt
dass unser staat bestehend aus bund und
ländern handlungsfähig ist wenn es
notwendig ist
ich möchte mal unterstützen also allen
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten war immer der ernst
der lage bewusst wir haben immer
entschieden und ich würde es auch
nochmal ganz klar sagen es gibt
niemanden der die einer maßnahme oder
den einweg kannte der alle probleme
gelöst hat sondern wir haben in den
ländern unterschiedliche erfahrungen
gemacht mit guten und schlechten zahlen
und zwar ohne ausnahme und wir haben
unsere erfahrungen miteinander
ausgetauscht und haben immer wieder nach
geschafft und so war es jetzt hier auch
wer nicht möchte auch noch einmal daran
erinnern im oktober und november sind
schon weitgehende beschlüsse gefasst
worden
es hat vor wenigen tagen noch ein papier
der leopoldina gegeben indem drin stand
und die empfehlung doch bitte am 4 0 ab
dem 24
dezember den einzelhandel einzuschränken
und sie sehen daran dass uns sehr wohl
bewusst ist wo wir stehen dass wir es
praktisch ab sofort jetzt machen so das
macht deutlich dass es hier keine
differenzen gibt wir müssen einfach
sehen herr söder ist auch schon darauf
eingegangen wir haben mit unterlagen wo
wir über die parlamente auch unsere
maßnahmen umsetzen müssen
wir haben die situation dass wir auch
die familien natürlich oder die
situation der familien berücksichtigen
müssen jetzt bei der umsetzung der
maßnahmen
uns hat das in den
zehn wochen gemeinsam immer wieder
beschäftigt wie machen wir es gut um
einerseits den gesundheitsschutz zu
gewährleisten und andererseits aber auch
die menschen mitzunehmen und ihnen die
chance zu geben sich auf die jeweiligen
maßnahmen einzurichten und einzustellen
das sind weitgehende einschnitte in
vielen familien ist das nicht so einfach
von heute auf morgen umzusetzen
ich habe in meiner stadt 52 prozent
alleinlebende oder alleinerziehende
damit muss ich umgehen dass auch die
eine chance brauchen ihre
familiensituation entsprechend oder ihre
situation am arbeitsplatz zu
organisieren dass es nicht sorglosigkeit
hat es die ganzen letzten wochen nicht
gegeben in keinem bundesland von keinem
ministerpräsidenten
aber es hat auch keinen gegeben der den
königsweg von anfang an wusste sondern
wir haben uns gemeinsam weiterentwickelt
und ich glaube wir haben uns in vielen
bereichen sehr erfolgreich gemeinsam
weiterentwickelt wir sind jetzt an einem
punkt wo wir sehen dass es bundesweit
mit diesen einzelnen schritten nicht
mehr geht sondern dass es jetzt wirklich
ein umfassendes herunterfahren der
kontakte geben muss und insofern gibt es
darauf auch die verständigung
wenn wir alles immer perfekt wüssten
dann wäre es ja ganz einfach aber wir
leben in einer demokratie mit einer
einzigartige herausforderung überall in
der welt ist es so dass bewohner immer
wieder neu aufflammt es gibt einige
länder die sind autoritär
die setzen auch nicht auf die
eigenverantwortung der menschen sondern
allein auf die staatsmacht es gibt
einige länder die sie nicht wie wir
mitten und geben von ländern
beispielsweise minseln australien habe
ich gelesen ist sehr erfolgreich unter
anderem war der seit monaten niemandes
land betreten das ausserrhoder wenn
unter strengsten quarantänevorschriften
wir haben eine gesellschaftliche form
eine demokratie eine lebendige eine
liberale die glaube ich auch diesen
bewährung stresstest bestehen kann
da dauert manches mal zwei tage länger
habe ich glaube dass wir jetzt schon
gemeinsam entschieden haben
trotzdem bin ich froh dass wir zu
entschieden haben und es liegt schon
auch an der am bewusstsein aller aber
schon auch an eindringlichen worten
willkommen sind auch vom
nochmal deswegen will ich das einfach
mal sagen ich war schon auch wichtig und
was mich jetzt persönlich betrifft ich
bedanke mich wirklich für die gute
zusammenarbeit auch mit herrn müller
muss ich jetzt sagen hat sehr geholfen
gestern noch einmal dass da alle sich
beteiligt haben
meine position zu den dingen ist seit
monaten bekannt sagte aber auch nicht
weil wir immer glauben bewussten ist
besser sondern weil wir von anfang an
stärker betroffen waren und in bayern
zum beispiel haben die längste
außengrenze wenn sie alle deutschen
bundesländer über 1000 kilometer wenn es
in den nachbarregionen die wir sehr
schätzen mögen riesige einträge gibt
dann ist es nur eine zeitfrage bis es
hier und dort sich entwickelt und planck
nach den letzten satz keiner ist vor
hohen infektionszahlen gefeiert wir sind
zum beispiel die schnelle setzt in
einigen bundesländern vorangeht die noch
vor wenigen wochen gesagt haben warum
setzen wir uns überhaupt zusammen
deswegen ist es entscheidend dass wir
nach vorne blicken und entscheiden und
nicht die frage stellen wer hat die
bessere figur abgegeben
das ist nämlich niemand es ist kein
menschen und deswegen konzentrieren uns
alle auf die gemeinschaftliche aufgabe
in einem demokratisch für den raum
system ja das ist was man da sich das
was wir alle genau hier verstehen müssen
das ist eine besondere situation
weihnachten und das neujahrs werden ganz
anders sein als wir das bisher erlebt
haben und trotzdem ist es richtig hier
gemeinsam entschlossen die kontakte zu
reduzieren um einander zu schützen
was die frage betrifft was machen wir
mit dem erweiterten möglichkeiten frei
zu nehmen werden die details jetzt zu
regeln und besprechen seien heute und
morgen denn es muss ja gesetzgebung zu
stande kommen damit das möglich ist in
der nächsten sitzungswoche des deutschen
bundestages der bundesminister für
arbeit und soziales ist bereits daran
die frage vorzubereiten und die
richtigen handlungsoptionen zu wählen da
wir hier einen überschaubaren zeitraum
haben um den es geht wird es sicher auch
möglich sein eine gute pragmatische
lösung zu
5 vielen dank damit möglichst viele
fragen zu wort kommen können möchte ich
sie bitten sich auf eine frage zu
beschränken
die nächste frage hat ja keener hast
schon z eine nachfrage zum thema impfen
frau bundeskanzlerin andere länder haben
ja bereits begonnen mit dem in
deutschland entwickelten impfstoff zu
impfen wann wird in deutschland der
erste mensch geimpft werden
und weil es ja in weiten teilen der
gesellschaft den sozialen medien eine
wachsende skepsis gibt beim thema impfen
können sie hier versichern dass der
impfstoff sicher ist kann man sich also
rote schlechtes gewissen impfen lassen
also die frage ob ein impfstoff sicher
ist wird ja von den zuständigen behörden
geprüft und wir haben dafür die
europäische arzneimittelagentur die für
diese prüfungen durch und wir wollen
natürlich dass das sorgfältig geschickt
und deshalb werden wir da auch keinen
politischen druck machen und die ema hat
das ist dieser europäische
arzneimittelagentur hat gesagt dass sie
bis zum 29 12
eine zulassung machen wird wir haben
heute den 13 12
also wir es noch einige tage warten
vielleicht hat das auch etwas früher
aber spätestens am 29
dann wird natürlich auch sofort der
impfstoff ausgeliefert in alle
europäischen länder im übrigen und dann
wird sehr schnell im januar die
möglichkeit seien zu wenige tage nach
der zulassung wird man natürlich dann
impfen und ich vertraue den europäischen
arzneimittelbehörden und den sach der
sachkunde die da waltet ist es im
übrigen so dass auch die nationalen
behörden dann nochmal ihre informationen
an die europäische behörde geben bei uns
dass das paul ehrlich institut das auch
seine sein sachverstand dort mit
einbringt also da mache ich mir keine
sorgen dass nicht der beste sachverstand
der in europa da ist auch wirklich
genutzt wird und deshalb kann dieser
impfstoff dann so zugelassen werden wir
auch
das auch gemacht wird das wird jetzt
noch kein impfstoff für kinder sein denn
sicherlich dann noch einige
randbedingungen gemacht werden und da
ist das dann glaube ich wichtig dass da
sorgfalt walten
vielen dank eine frage an die beiden
ministerpräsidenten müller und herrn
söder kita schließungen und grund
schulschließungen insbesondere sind ja
ein großes problem nicht nur für die
bildungsgerechtigkeit sondern einfach
auch ein betreuungsproblem für
berufstätige eltern
das haben sie gesagt wird notbetreuung
geben uns wird urlaubstag geben können
sie das ein bisschen konkretisieren wer
hat anspruch auf die notbetreuung wir
werden in zwei stunden glaube ich werden
wir mit dem so nah zusammen kommen und
werden das genau miteinander besprechen
wie wir das jetzt umsetzen wir haben ja
erfahrung aus dem frühjahr mit der note
betreuung und auch für wen wir das
anbieten können
das wort macht schon deutlich worum es
geht
in notlagen wird hier etwas oder für
notlagen wird etwas organisiert wir
wollen weitestgehend kontakte vermeiden
ich sage es nochmal das ist das ziel und
insofern gibt es hier auch in unseren
beschluss die dringende aufforderung
eben auch zu sehen wie man es anders
organisieren kann jenseits des präsents
betriebes in schule und kita wie man es
familie organisieren kann es gibt
entsprechende unterstützung auch mit den
digitalen lernangeboten dort wo für den
kita-bereich es nicht anders zu
organisieren es gibt es eine
notbetreuung aber es wird ein geringer
umfang sein das muss ich so sagen
detaillierter kann ich ihnen jetzt vor
der senatssitzung noch nicht nennen es
wichtig dass meine einheitliche regelung
haben wir haben ja vorher ganz
unterschiedliche auffassungen von
wechsel distanz unterricht und ähnliches
mehr beispielsweise und es zeigt sich
immer an der neuesten studien das obwohl
die kita wenig symptomatischer fälle hat
offenkundig das zeigen auch tests in
österreich sehr viele asymptomatische
entwicklungen sind das heißt der kleine
hohe ansteckung sein wenn dann ganz dann
richtig so
sie haben völlig recht die betreuung es
spielt eine zentrale rolle deswegen ist
es ja ein dreiklang der existierte
deutschland besteht erstens in der
in der grundschule wenn es möglich ist
distanz unterrichts machen wenn es
möglich ist wenn nicht ist es zweiter
die notbetreuung zu organisieren
notbetreuung des theaters braucht sagen
jetzt einfach mal so im allgemeinen
werden im frühjahr und sehe auch sehr
knappe systemrelevante berufe
verständigt in der meinung für bayern
würde ich sagen wir es braucht zu
organisieren das muss nicht nur beruf
sein sondern muss einfach gar nicht
anders organisierbar ist ja wir können
die eltern völlig allein lassen
aber was ganz entscheidendes eltern
können eben am urlaub nehmen die hatten
es im frühjahr ausmacht bezahlten urlaub
im internet für so eine entschädigung
bekommen sind
das glaube ich hilft sehr und die
arbeitgeber noch mal dringend bitten es
handelt sich um drei tage drei tage also
ist nicht mehr jetzt drei tage jetzt
keine wochenlange der parteitage und für
diese drei tagen ihr glaube ich kann
home office und gemeinsamkeit auch
bestehen das gilt sowohl in der kulanz
der arbeitgeber als auch ford ist glaube
ich so dass also wenn wir die drei tage
nicht organisieren können in deutschland
eine gute betreuung zu finden entweder
schaffen es die eltern selber es gibt
tatsächlich eltern können ist nicht das
linke kräfte beispielsweise da ist dann
entweder notbetreuung die möglichkeit
oder wenn es gar nicht anders geht dann
die eltern ihm einfach zu hause oder an
einen einlauf partner oder beide oder
ein ich bin alleinerziehend ist
natürlich dass häufig der fall
und dann bekommt man entsprechenden
ausgleich das ist sehr dankbar wieder
das tor der bund auch ihr entgegenkommt
und das mitschneiden ländern mehr als
drei tage sind also jetzt vor
weihnachten sind es drei bayern hat bis
zum 10 januar ferien andere länder das
auch aber nicht alle
nicht alle haben bis zum 10 januar
fehlen fünf wochen am stück ist und
irgendwann mal sehen und die menschen
haben sich in dieser weihnachtsziel
esther zeit ohnehin schon beschäftigt
ist dabei
also was die eigene community toren
nächste frage hätte ich sage bloomberg
frau bundeskanzlerin erlauben sie dass
ich kurz eine frage zum thema praxis
stelle und zwar wenn sie mir sagen es
gibt der britischen presse sehr harte
vorwürfe jetzt gegen sie dass sie unter
anderem zu hart verhandelt haben oder
eine zu harte position hatten und daher
möglicherweise die gespräche scheitern
drohe und nachher sprechen von frau von
der leyen und herr johns miteinander
während sie für eine fortsetzung der
gespräche um doch noch möglicherweise
ein agreement hinzukriegen
er ist mit sie gemeint das besagt dass
sie zu hart handelt also sie also also
eben ich als grieche hat die europäische
union ein
also sie passen sie werden ja in der
britischen presse wenn ich es richtig
gesehen habe als hauptschuldiger dafür
dass kosten resultieren zu wissen also
ich hab überhaupt nicht verhandelt und
verhandle auch gar nicht sondern die
europäische kommission verhandelt die
kommissionspräsidentin sie haben es
erwähnt mit boris johnson michel barnier
für uns alle
diese verhandlungsposition hat sie auch
gar nicht verändert und dass die
verhandlungen nicht einfach sind ist ja
klar großbritannien scheidet aus dem
binnenmarkt aus und mit dem ausscheiden
aus dem binnenmarkt müssen wir natürlich
darauf achten dass ich auch im
zeitverlauf also wenn sich die
rechtslage zwischen großbritannien und
der europäischen union weiter
auseinanderentwickelt faire
wettbewerbsbedingungen da sind aber wie
gesagt deutschland verhandelt da
überhaupt nicht als einzelner teilnehmer
sondern alles verhandelt
der europäischen union ich bin natürlich
bin ich der meinung dass die dass wir
alles versuchen sollten um ein ergebnis
zu bekommen das es versteht sich von
selbst und die kommissionspräsidentin
hat uns ja auch berichtet während des
europäischen rates und jeder möglichkeit
noch zu einem ergebnis zu kommen ist
hochwillkommen
herr rinke von reuters bundeskanzlerin
bei der ersten welle haben gerichte ja
eine ganze reihe von den verschärfungen
gekippt was macht sie sicher dass jetzt
bei diesen zusätzlichen starken
einschränkungen die beschlossen wurden
das diesmal nicht so sein wird unter
scholz eine nachfrage zu den finanzen
sie hatten elf milliarden erwähnt mit
wie viel geld rechnen sie denn noch
darüber hinaus denn also da hat ja schon
angekündigt er kann sich nicht
vorstellen dass nach dem zehnten ersten
plötzlich alles wieder aufgehoben wird
und so sein wird wie vorher
wir leben ja immer weiter unter den
pandemischen bedingungen und solange wir
nicht eine gewisse immunität durch das
impfen haben werden wir immer unter
diesen bedingungen leben wie die jeder
jeweils ausgestaltet sind das muss man
sehen
ihre frage nach den gerichtsprozessen im
frühjahr die haben sich im grunde erst
ergeben als wir angefangen haben zu
lockern
weil da der die frage der
gleichbehandlung immer sehr im raume
stand ich glaube jetzt wo wir so ein so
harte schritte machen
da stellen sich diese fragen nicht so
stark wir haben erlebt dass öffnen es
dann immer sehr schwer weil dann eben
gefragt wird wer wird im verhältnis zu
wem gleich verhandelt und was ist jetzt
verhältnismäßig was ist richtig aber ich
glaube hier auch angesichts der zahl der
toten angesichts des exponentiellen
anstieg in dem wir wieder sind sind
diese maßnahmen so erkennbar notwendig
dass ich da nicht mit großen
schwierigkeiten rechnen zumal wir das
dann auch bundeseinheitlicher
durchführen also das sehe ich
als gegeben an zumal das auch jetzt
übereinstimmung ist mit dem § 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes wo wir die
instanzen noch mal festgelegt haben und
ein blick auf die landkarte zeigt dass
das geboten
ansonsten steht der schlüssel wir haben
einfach jetzt auf eine andere rechtliche
grundlage mit dem verweis der
bundeskanzlerin wird dass er deutlich
wir haben eine andere rechtliche
grundlage auf der wir bundesweit auch in
den ländern anders agieren können und
wir haben ja vor allen dingen auch noch
mal einen vorteil gehabt zudem
grundrechts einschränkungen also sowohl
bei dem demonstrationsrecht wie auch bei
der religionsfreiheit und das sind
natürlich auch die dinge mit denen wir
jetzt ja auch besonders sensibel umgehen
da gibt es wie auch bei mir zb im
parlament in berlin auch ein besonderes
augenmerk drauf und wir haben aus diesen
urteilen auch gelernt aber die
rechtsgrundlage ist jetzt auch eine
andere als eine der hauptgründe der
gerichte war immer die reine an eine
ganz einfache schema der
gleichheitsgrundsatz und dadurch dass
wir ein politisches gleichstellen er
fällt diese endlos differenzierungen die
einer der gründe war warum fitnessstudio
warum dies ist nicht darum was anders
weitgehend weg und aber auch noch mal
zur wahrheit zumindest in bayern wurden
von allen verfahren nur knapp über 2
knapp drei prozent verloren
bei einer unzahl von von verfahren also
das zeigt schon auch die juristisch
dicht und wie stabil
auch die entscheidung waren weil es
immer so sie berichten immer gerne über
die entscheidung die negativ ausgeht
aber nicht über die hunderten von
entscheidungen die abgelehnt werden aber
positiv allein bei den masken gibt es
unzählige entscheidungen von überzeugten
masten gegnern die immer wieder
abgelehnt worden
bis hin zum verfassungsgericht wurden
infektionsschutz verordnungen mwst
akzeptiert und auf ihre finanz frage zu
antworten
der deutsche bundestag hat gerade den
haushalt für das jahr 2021 beschlossen
und in diesem sinn vorgesehen für
wirtschaftshilfen 39 5 milliarden euro
und außerdem zusätzliche mittel
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der korona
pandemie von 35 milliarden euro
da musste hat sich vorbehalten der
haushaltsausschuss 20 milliarden davon
im gespräch geblieben dann auszugeben
sie sind also entsprechend festgelegt
aber da ist doch wenn man das gesamt
betrachtet eine große vorsorge für alles
was passieren kann getroffen
die maßnahme kostet pro monat so viel
das habe ich ihm vorgetragen damit man
die dimensionen der förderung wahrnimmt
und auch mit welcher ernsthaftigkeit
wird wirklich das würde ich schon als
wort verwenden das schicksal vieler
unternehmen unternehmer und alle
beschäftigten in diesen betrieben im
blick haben um ihn in dieser situation
bei seite zu stehen und das glaube ich
ist schon etwas was notwendig und auch
richtig ist gleichzeitig ist es
natürlich klar dass wir immer gucken
müssen was passiert wenn es länger
dauert und deshalb habe ich ihm gesagt
dass wir doch vom deutschen bundestag
einen großen spielraum bekommen haben zu
helfen wo es notwendig ist die letzte
frage hat frau marx vom rbb danke sie
hat uns wohin jetzt schon selber
angesprochen dass die maßnahmen die sie
schon im november getroffen haben nicht
die wirkung gehabt haben die man sich
erhofft hat jetzt haben sie ja
eigentlich eine erweiterung dieser
maßnahmen also durch weitere
schließungen
wir hatten im vorfeld auch oft
ankündigung verteilen von fc2 masken
lüftungssysteme in den schulen und was
da noch alles an ankündigung kam aber in
der praktischen umsetzung ist es dann da
sehr still geworden
was macht sie denn jetzt so sicher oder
woher haben sie das vertrauen dass jetzt
diese maßnahmen wirklich funktionieren
dass das jetzt klappt naja das vertrauen
kann man daher haben dass auf der einen
seite via erfahrungen aus dem frühjahr
haben das heißt wir wissen wie wir jetzt
doch mit kontakt reduzierungen rechnen
können und zweitens haben wir dieses
vertrauen auch aus dem was wir aus
unseren nachbarländern
sehen wo ja auch eine ganze reihe von
beschränkungen zum teil noch härtere
beschränkungen als wir sie jetzt haben
gemacht wurden und wo man dann nach
einigen tagen sieht wie sich das
natürlich auswirkt was wir jetzt sehen
müssen ist dass wir natürlich noch eine
ganze reihe von tagen also an die zehn
tage haben werden in denen das weiter
steigt weil die infektion die heute
morgen übermorgen erkannt werden ja
schon in der vergangenheit stattgefunden
haben und dann erst eine verbesserung
der lage überhaupt sichtbar ist das
heißt wir haben jetzt schon einen recht
langen weg vor uns und was die rzb zwei
masken anbelangt so werden vor
weihnachten jetzt noch das hat er der
gesundheitsminister angedeutet drei pro
berechtigten ausgegeben durch die
apotheken und die anderen dann im januar
das heißt also da wird das versprechen
jetzt in diesen tagen genau umgesetzt
für ihr kommen und noch einen schönen
dritten advent tja liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer so weit also die
pressekonferenz aus berlin zu den neuen
corona maßnahmen wir fassen zusammen
markus söder sagt es so corona ist außer
kontrolle geraten
die kanzlerin sagt es so das was wir
bisher an maßnahmen ergriffen haben hat
nicht gereicht deshalb hat man sich für
neue maßnahmen entschieden und die sehen
so aus ab mittwoch wird der einzelhandel
schließen
bis auf getränkemärkte reformhäuser baby
fachmärkte apotheken sanitätshäuser
drogerien optiker hörgeräteakustiker
tankstellen kfz werkstätten
fahrradwerkstätten banken und sparkassen
poststellen reinigungen waschsalons
zeitungsverkauf tierbedarf märkte
futtermittel werkte und
weihnachtsbaumverkauf das alles wird
geöffnet bleiben aber um an der stelle
schon mal die frage der userin wäre
schubert zu beantworten auch die
supermärkte werden schließen kauft
klopapier
nein liebe frau schubert liebe frau
lieber zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
bitte tun sie das nicht hamsterkäufe
sind genau das was in dieser situation
nicht geraten ist und die supermärkte
bleiben offen
was schließen wird sind die friseure
also alle dienstleistungsbetriebe im
bereich der körperpflege und was auch
schließen wird zumindest im
präsenzunterricht in schulen und
kindertagesstätten die schulen sind
angehalten auf online unterricht
umzustellen und die kitas werden je nach
ausgestaltung in den ländern eine
notbetreuung anbieten was silvester
angeht gilt ein versammlungsverbot und
der verkauf von böllern wird verboten
werden
vor silvester kann man also keine
feuerwerkskörper kaufen was weihnachten
angeht die frage nach den gottesdiensten
wird noch beantwortet werden müssen da
hieß es gerade in der pressekonferenz
dass sich das innenministerium mit den
kirchen in verbindung setzen wird um
eine lösung für die gottesdienste an den
feiertagen zu finden
ein kurzer blick in die community zeigt
dass die einschätzungen der userinnen
und user sehr unterschiedlich sind so
schreibt zum beispiel auf youtube
conscious action network gemeinsam so
geht s los gemeinsam eine krasse
infektions und sterbefälle verhindern
aus liebe für unsere mitmenschen
das ist doch eine schöne
weihnachtsaktion ebenfalls auf youtube
schreibt tomo verglichen mit früheren
generationen mit einschränkungen und
verzicht ist das hier echt harmlos und
alle jammern das land geht unter kommt
mal runter simon preise schreibt schnell
und entschlossen gehandelt das ich nicht
lache gepennt haben die und das ist
genau meine frage an nicole diekmann die
uns zugeschaltet ist aus berlin
unsere korrespondentin dort liebe nicole
jim schreibt hätten wir im oktober einen
harten lockdown gestartet hätte man
schon früher auf merkel gehört werden
wir jetzt nicht in so einer miserablen
lage
was ist deine einschätzung nach diesen
neuen maßnahmen die da eben verkündet
wurden ja meine einschätzung ist dass
man genau das heute beziehungsweise
vielleicht auch im vorfeld der letzten
tage diskutiert hat denn wer genau
hingehört hat hat die rollenverteilung
so wahrgenommen
merkel hat informiert söder hat nochmal
appelliert das ist ja so seine rolle die
er sich für sich gefunden hat in dieser
corona krise sich inszenieren als der
mann als der verständnisvolle aber
mahnen
ich sag's mal vater ein bisschen
intoniert er das ja scholz hat noch mal
finanzminister schäuble hat noch mal
sehr nüchtern
die wirtschaftlichen aspekte die man
auch gesprochen hat in der
ministerpräsident in einer runde
erläutert und berlins regierender
bürgermeister müller
er hatte die rolle desjenigen der
erklären sollte warum man das nicht
alles schon vorher beschlossen hat
beziehungsweise sich dafür rechtfertigen
musste wollte in die offensive gehen um
zu erklären doch immer das vorher nicht
schon getan hat also ja
auch die antwort von der kanzlerin auf
die erste frage eines journalisten ob
sie sich nicht bestätigt fühlt in der
viel vorsicht vorsichtigeren positionen
die sie ja die ganze zeit inne hatte da
sagte sie sie wolle heute nicht
zurückschauen was ja im grunde heißt ich
möchte diese fragen hier heute nicht
diskutieren ich bin froh dass wir uns
heute beschlüsse gefasst haben
also es scheint der große einigkeit
gegeben zu haben dass man das alles
schon hätte er beschließen müssen ja das
heißt also man kann sagen dass diese
taktik der politik dass die bürger
vernünftiger sein sollen als die politik
ihr quasi vorgibt zu sein
gescheitert ist denn das ist ja quasi
der worst case eigentlich wenn man sich
diese gesamte pandemie lage anguckt oder
ja das ist immer gemein und schwierig zu
sagen die bürger oder bürgerinnen es
gibt fehler anscheinend oder manche die
sich nicht vernünftig verhalten haben
markus söder hat sie auch eben noch mal
angesprochen die querdenker die ja trotz
der jetzt schon geltende maßnahmen noch
demonstrieren wollten
also ja man hat es auf mehr vernunft
gehofft auf mehr verantwortung ich
glaube es war angela merkel die eben
auch sagte die kontakte seien in den
guten zeiten jetzt in den vergangenen
wochen um 40 prozent reduziert worden
was viel zu wenig sei aber es gab auch
noch mal ein dankeschön an diejenigen
die sich an die bisher geltenden regeln
gehalten haben die käufer nicht in den
chat gucke dann sehe ich dass ganz viele
userinnen und user sich mit dem thema
schule beschäftigen
da sind viele die schreiben offenbar
noch klausuren und arbeiten die letzte
woche die einen freuen sich weil sie
glauben dass sie jetzt darum herum
kommen die aber sagen die moment mal
also das geht ja jetzt so auch nicht
kannst du gerade nochmal die lage
zusammen fassen wie sie sich jetzt an
den schulen gestaltet ja das wurde
besonders klar dass man da noch nicht
ganz ausgegoren ist als mann markus dazu
gehört hat der zwischenzeitlich auch
immer wieder als bayerischer
ministerpräsident gesprochen hat das war
überhaupt nicht zu überhören die
regelung ist ja jetzt dass möglichst
alle kinder zu hause bleiben sollen
sowohl in den schulen als auch in den
kitas das ist ja das was man eigentlich
die ganze zeit
vermeiden sollte deswegen wurde auch
noch einmal darauf verwiesen es geht
jetzt nur um wenige tage
weil sich das in vielen bundesländern
mit den weihnachtsferien sowieso
überschneidet mehr oder weniger aber
markus söder sagte bei uns wird die
regelung seien die eltern die es leisten
können lassen ihre kinder zu hause
er verwies dann auch nochmal auf das
frühjahr da war das sehr klar geregelt
mit definierten systemrelevanten berufen
so hieß dass die eltern die in solchen
brocken für arbeiteten konnten ihre
kinder weiterhin in kitas und schulen
schicken
davon will man jetzt abweichen zumindest
in bayern dh die eltern wie es brauchen
können ihre kinder schicken wie das
definiert ist wer das nachprüfen will
wie man das belegen möchte das wurde
eben klar ist überhaupt noch nicht
logisch also ich glaube dass es für
eltern jetzt dilemma gibt es nämlich
einmal für sich zu definieren brauche
ich es unbedingt oder brauche ich es
nicht und dann im zweifel eventuell
zähneknirschend mit schlechtem gewissen
das kind dann doch noch zu schicken
das ist ein großes fragezeichen das nach
dieser pressekonferenz und auch mit dem
papier das uns allen jetzt vorliegt noch
besteht
ich möchte ja noch mal bei den kindern
bleiben
bayerns ministerpräsident hat gesagt die
stade zeit wie man das in bayern
menschen entsteht vor der tür lasst uns
doch das als positive familienzeit
genießen
jetzt ist die lage aber halt nicht so
dass in allen familien weihnachten
bedeutet vier menschen sitzen
einträchtig unterm baum essen plätzchen
und singen heilige nacht und schon gar
nicht über einen längeren zeitraum jeder
kennt das dass man nach bestimmten
weihnachtsfeiertagen auch die schnauze
voll hat von der familie und das hört
sich jetzt lustiger an als es klingt
denn das ist ja auch ein großes problem
in familien mit häuslicher gewalt mit
aggression mit menschen die alleine
gelassen werden mit kindern die alleine
gelassen werden und das ist ja auch ein
grund dafür gewesen dass man gesagt hat
man lässt die schulen und die kitas
ebenso lange auf um diese menschen vor
allem diese kinder nicht zu verlieren
wie ist denn jetzt die reaktion der
politik darauf gerade jetzt vor diesen
zeiten die uns bevorstehen
da hat zum beispiel gerade eben noch mal
berlins regierender bürgermeister und
vorsitzender der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz müller
sich darauf bezogen hier in berlin bei
uns ist die ist die rate der allein
erziehenden relativ hoch und gibt es
auch viele sagen wir mal brennpunkte in
denen auch von häuslicher gewalt die
rede ist wobei im moment ja immer noch
die erhebung fehlen die das letztendlich
belegen es gibt ja ist ja man ist da in
einem dilemma man hat die ganze zeit
eben versucht so viel wie möglich offen
zu halten jetzt gibt es aber neue
studien
da hat er hat soeben auch noch einmal
darauf hingewiesen wonach kinder und
kleinkinder eben anscheinend doch
ansteckender sind als man das gedacht
hat und dass viele daran ist dass
anscheinend kinder sich anstecken können
infiziert sind aber überhaupt keine
symptome zeigen das heißt wir
erwachsenen halten die für gesund und
stecken uns im zweifel dann bei denen an
ich glaube diesen umstand ist auch die
tatsache geschuldet dass eben
weihnachten ansonsten so einer gesamt
isolation führen könnte dass er
zumindest für die weihnachtsfeiertage ja
noch mal die regeln locker dass man sich
maximal mit fünf menschen aus zwei
haushalten treffen wird da möchte ich
gerne den blick auf den einzelhandel
richten vorher aber vielleicht noch ein
kleiner appell an die community alle die
offenbar ein riesengroßes ski-star
problem haben diskutiert das vielleicht
einfach an anderer stelle und nicht in
unserem chat weil das unglaublich
erfüllend ist und das ist nicht das
thema und alle die hier hält geht
einfach nur eine runde schlafen oder
guckt eine schöne serie aber lasst bitte
denen die hier ernsthafte fragen stellen
die chance das auch zu tun und das tun
viele zum beispiel fragt lied hawass
über youtube was ist mit den friseuren
kann mir das jemand sagen ja das können
wir die sind ab mittwoch zu genau wie
alle anderen dienstleistungen die
körpernahe sind wie zum beispiel
massagestudios es sei denn es gibt
medizinische notwendigkeiten für
fußpflege oder ähnliches physiotherapie
das wird bleiben
aber nicole zum thema einzelhandel
verharrt 66 fragt was für hilfen wird es
geben und da war ja auch olaf scholz
jetzt extra auch mit dabei um diese
frage zu beantworten
genau also zum einen
einmal noch nicht mit den zahlen
anzufangen es mit weiterhin restaurants
und gaststätten möglich sein ihre dinge
mahlzeiten außer haus zu verkaufen und
es die über rückens hilfen werden
verlängert sagt scholz ein beispiel ist
ab mittwoch machen die läden dicht es
wird abschreibungsmöglichkeiten geben
für jetzt nicht verkaufte waren und es
geht um bis zu 500.000 euro pro monat
für direkt oder indirekt geschlossene
betriebe wie er das eben nannte die
gezahlt werden können das bedeutet
sollte ich es verstanden wenn ich zum
beispiel ein einen betrieb mit der dazu
liefert an einen betrieb der nun
schließen muss dann kann ich natürlich
auch nicht mehr produzieren
beziehungsweise absetzen um die wird es
da wo gehen und dann nannte scholz eine
konkrete zahl nämlich elf milliarden
unterstützung
die könnten da zusammenkommen bis zu 11
milliarden
er nannte aber auch einen konkreten
zeitraum nämlich einen monat das heißt
anscheinend hat man über diesen monat
noch nicht weiter nachgedacht
dann gibt es eine anschlussfrage nicole
von wolfgang zeh der schreibt über
facebook ich frage mich wo das ganze
geld herkommen soll
er hat schon noch mal relativ
optimistisch auf den haushalt verwiesen
den mann da gerade diese woche im
bundestag hatte und machte jetzt nicht
den eindruck als würde er sich da sehr
große sorgen machen da muss man
natürlich dazu sagen dass es auch
politik das ist eine aufgabe da
zuversichtlich zu wirken aber so war
eben zusammengefasst die die nachricht
die aus dieser pressekonferenz zu diesem
punkt aufgabe
nicole es gab auch den hinweis darauf
dass man das erst ab mittwoch machen
könnte weil es natürlich auch
gesetzgebungsprozesse gibt und landtage
die jetzt oder kabinette die da mit
einbezogen werden können kannst du auch
noch mal darauf hinweisen was das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz dass er mitte
november beschlossen wurde
möglicherweise auch für auswirkungen
jetzt im nachhinein auf diese verordnung
von heute hat naja das
infektionsschutzgesetz ist ja unter sehr
großem getöse wir erinnern uns wie viel
wie viel ärger ist darum gegeben hat
wieviel mobilmachung dagegen auch
politisch vor allem von seiten der afg
es gegeben hat
es geht darum den vorwurf zu entkräften
dass hier demokratie ausgehebelt wird
was ein sehr weit reichender vorwurf ist
der eben auch politisch
instrumentalisiert worden ist es geht
darum dass die länderparlamente aktiv
beteiligt werden
an diesen entscheidungen dass eben
dieser vorwurf nicht mehr greift es
würde hier in einem gremium das so nicht
legitimiert ist nämlich der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das hier
beschlüsse gefasst würden die das ist ja
auch so in die grundrechte weitreichend
eingreifen und das politisch nicht
legitimiert ist und das heißt jetzt
genau für diese maßnahmen die heute
verkündet wurden wie geht das jetzt
weiter also für berlin kann ich zum
beispiel sagen da wird jetzt hier
nochmal im senat darüber beraten und
dann werden diese beschlüsse so
umgesetzt wie man das richtig das ist
auch noch mal eine wichtige information
auch nochmal hier markus söder markus
söder der sehr darauf bedacht war in
dieser pressekonferenz auch noch einmal
auf die einigkeit hinzuweisen die unter
dem ministerpräsidenten heute geherrscht
hat ja die beratungen heute haben sehr
sehr kurz nur gedauert das war eine
beratung nach einer stunde wurden wir
schon zur pressekonferenz eingeladen bzw
pressekonferenz was aber auch zur
wahrheit gehört es dass in den
vergangenen tagen natürlich verhandelt
wurde weil man eben heute schnell und
eigentlich auftreten wollte diese
einigkeit gab es zum anderen aber sagte
markus söder also für bayern könne er
sagen dass die heute gefassten
beschlüsse maximal
gesetzt würden das bedeutet im
umkehrschluss dass die länder gar auch
noch einmal für sich modifizieren können
was sie für sich für richtig halten das
ist ja auch in der vergangenheit
passiert und hat soviel unwillen geführt
das heißt also wir können uns darauf
einstellen dass dann doch wieder in den
nächsten tagen von dieser
einheitlichkeit die ja selbst immer
wieder beschworen wird von den
ministerpräsidentinnen abgewichen wird
und dass man dann doch wieder gucken
muss was gilt wo und kann ich vielleicht
da irgendwie mehr vermittelt
familienmitglieder treffen als da kann
ich irgendwie da doch später hinreisen
als da oder glaubst du dass es an
solchen wesentlichen stellen tatsächlich
einheitlich sein wird ich sage jetzt mal
dass ich glaube mit betonung auf glauben
dass es diesmal nicht so viele ausnahmen
geben wird weil man nämlich in den
vergangenen tagen auch aus ländern wie
zb schleswig holstein oder auch
mecklenburg vorpommern wo die zahlen
verglichen mit zum beispiel bayern immer
noch relativ niedrig sind gehört hat wir
brauchen jetzt schnell ein treffen aller
ministerpräsidenten mit der kanzlerin
manuela schwesig aus
mecklenburg-vorpommern war da war da
wirklich am dringendsten von allen die
appelliert hat solch ein treffen
möglichst schnell abzuhalten die wollte
das schon am freitag
und das waren die länder die bisher dann
immer mal wieder gesagt haben naja
natürlich sind die zahlen hoch bei uns
sind sie nicht so hoch
wir schauen mal vielleicht lässt sich da
noch was machen und von den salinen hier
scheint man jetzt ab vielen dank nicole
an dieser stelle bis bis zu dieser
stelle einst möchte ich dir gerne noch
mit in diesem dritten advent geben
nämlich einen kommentar von steffen dyck
auf facebook er schreibt kein silvester
feuerwerk uhr am meine katzen finden das
super haben sie mir gerade maut ich
nehme an da ist er einer der wenigen die
das gut findet zumindest hier im chat
aber vielen dank steffen dyck für den
kommentar und vielen dank nicole nach
berlin
und wir schauen uns nochmal an im detail
worauf sie sich geeinigt haben wenn ich
richtig liege dann liegt uns dazu eine
grafik vor einzelhandelsgeschäfte mit
ausnahme von lehrern des täglichen
bedarfs müssen ebenso schließen
wie friseursalons kosmetikstudios und
massagepraxen die präsenzpflicht an
schulen wird mindestens bis zum 10
januar ausgesetzt und es gibt ein
verkaufsverbot für bella auch der
alkoholkonsum in der öffentlichkeit wird
verboten
tja darüber sprechen wir gleich mit dem
virologen doktor martin stürmer aber bis
dahin versuche ich noch mal
zusammenzufassen was denn darüber hinaus
beschlossen wurde
denn im chat wird eine frage auch ganz
oft gestellt die wir aber ehrlicherweise
auch trotz mehrfacher versuche das zu
recherchieren noch nicht beantworten
können nämlich die frage ob baumärkte
geschlossen werden die deutschen
entscheiden das unglaublich wichtig zu
finden ob sie noch in den baumarkt
können oder nicht
es wird viel aufgelistet an geschäften
die offen sind aber es tatsächlich ist
in dem beschluss der da uns vorliegt von
den baumärkten nicht die rede also wenn
wir das beantworten können tun wir das
aber jetzt nutzen wir die gelegenheit um
uns tatsächlich auf das zu konzentrieren
was diese ganze pandemie ausgelöst hat
nämlich das virus und seine bekämpfung
das tun wir wie gesagt mit dr martin
stürmer er ist virologe leiter eines
medizinlabors und lehrbeauftragte für
virologie an der universität frankfurt
da ist ja hallo guten morgen herr dr
stürmer an diesem dritten advent sie
haben das mit verfolgt und sind
informiert über die beschlüsse
was ist ihre einschätzung als virologe
dazu ja sind recht viele wichtige punkte
angesprochen worden
ich fange mal mit dem man was mich mit
am meisten gestört hatte in den ersten
beschlüssen
diese ausnahmeregelung zu weihnachten
und silvester das ist ja jetzt in einer
durchaus anderen form neu gestaltet
worden so dass man da durchaus besser
mit mit leben kann als virologe
insgesamt sind an vielen stellen woran
auch kontakte aktuell haben
beschränkungen auferlegt worden und auch
das finde ich sehr gut und insgesamt
kann man schon sagen dass heute auch ein
sehr gutes bild abgegeben worden ist von
seiten regierung und länder chefs und
chefinnen dass man der einheitliches
bild gezeigt hat und auch sehr sehr
schnell
und konsequent diese maßnahmen auch
verkündet hat und auch zeitlich sehr nah
umsetzen wird
sie sagen sehr sehr schnell und sehr
konsequent aber man kann ja schon die
frage stellen warum diese maßnahmen
nicht schon vor vier wochen getroffen
worden
ja das kann man sicherlich immer das
wird man im verlauf der pandemie wird
man irgendwo eine stelle erkennen können
im nachhinein wo man sagt das hätte man
vorher besser schneller machen können
ich gebe ihnen recht nachhinein sind die
maßnahmen die wir jetzt also noch
downlight kennengelernt haben nicht in
der form erfolgreich gewesen wie wir es
uns gewünscht hätten
aber ich denke aufgrund der erfahrung
aus der ersten lockdown zeit aber doch
schon gesehen wenn man ganz konsequent
alles hat zu macht dass man nicht
unbedingt
oder dass man sich viele viele nachteile
auch erkauft abgesehen von der
biologischen und da hab ich habe diese
noch downlight mitgetragen in der
hoffnung dass er mit der gezielten
maßnahmen eben das gleiche ziel
erreichen und ich denke wir haben jetzt
alle erkannt dass es so nicht weitergeht
und dementsprechend finde ich jetzt auch
dass man von der seite der der regierung
ihr sehr sehr gut reagiert und nicht
erst wie zb auch die leopoldina gesagt
hat erst auf weihnachten zum beispiel
reagiert das hatte natürlich auch den
grund dass man gesehen hat dass für den
einzelhandel diese bevorstehende woche
die umsatzstärkste woche des ganzen
jahres ist und nach dem letzten jahr war
das natürlich umso wichtiger klar gerade
für kleine händler dass sie das
weihnachtsgeschäft rettet und nun fällt
das auch aus was können sie dann als
virologe dazu sagen wie sehr sind die
leute die jetzt bummeln gegangen sind
oder vielleicht gar nicht so sehr
bummeln sondern einfach nur ins geschäft
rein geschenk kaufen wieder raus wie
sehr sind die betreiber dieser pandemie
ja das problem ist ja dass wir gar nicht
so genau wissen wo wirklich der exakte
treiber der pandemie ist wird
wahrscheinlich alles von allem ein
bisschen sein wenn man jetzt den
einzelhandel und und dieses geschäfts
wochenenden vorstellen werden sicherlich
viele menschen zum adventswochenende in
die innenstädte stürmen ihre einkäufe
erledigen sie müssen dort irgendwie
hinkommen öffentlichen personen
nahverkehr benutzen oder das auto in
irgendeiner form und dann wird ein paar
plätze in parkhäusern
überall gedränge entstehen und auch wenn
wir natürlich viel zeit dort im freien
verbringen und in den geschäften der
reduktion der menschen schon auch hatten
ist trotzdem ein nicht unerhebliches
risiko auch dadurch gegeben weil wir
eben immer noch sehr viele kontakte zu
lassen
und wer gerade auch noch im kontext dass
dann vielleicht da noch ein
glühweinstand aufgebaut ist und es da
vielleicht auch mal was zum essen gibt
an einem anderen stand da sind viele
sachen die zusammenkommen und insofern
so bitter es für den einzelhandel
natürlich ist ist es nur einer der konz
guten konsequenzen reaktionen
die nächste frage ist natürlich die der
privaten zusammenkünfte sie haben gerade
gesagt da wo viele menschen
zusammenkommen dann wird es einfach
schwierig jetzt steht weihnachten vor
der tür
die gerade bekannt gegebenen beschlüsse
sehen vor dass die kontakt
beschränkungen weiter bestehen bleiben
und private zusammenkünfte auf den
eigenen und einen weiteren haushalt
beschränkt sind auf maximal fünf
personen kinder bis 14 jahre sind
hiervon ausgenommen und die bundesländer
haben eigene regelungen dafür
lockerungen über die weihnachtsfeiertage
aber wie es danach aussieht wird es die
auch nicht geben das heißt weihnachten
wirklich wirklich im allerkleinsten
kreis was ist ihre empfehlung als
virologe wie sollte man weihnachten in
diesem jahr feiern
ja ich kann mich dem appell von von frau
merkel und herrn söder tempel da nur
anschließen
wirklich das auch alles auf ein minimum
reduzieren was irgendwo möglich ist also
ich denke großartige familie feiern sind
mit diesen beschlüssen ja eh nicht drin
man darf sich innerhalb der familie ja
noch treffen auch zu weihnachten
aber grundsätzlich ist hier tatsächlich
auch für dieses jahr weniger auf jeden
fall mehr
aber wo sie den privaten bereich
angesprochen haben das ist natürlich
nach wie vor der sektor der mann
insgesamt am wenigsten kontrollieren
kann
und da denke ich ist der bayerische weg
das ausgangs beschränkung und ausgangs
ja wirklich leistungseinschränkungen
angeht meiner meinung nach ein guter weg
weil man damit insgesamt den verkehr zu
privaten feiern auch noch mal reduziert
wir haben das ja teilweise in lockt in
den hot spot regionen wo ausgangs
beschränkungen tatsächlich auch gelten
und ich glaube dass da eine einheitliche
regelungen gerne nach incidence
gestaffelt auch heute durchaus hätte
verkündet werden können dann würde ich
gerne lieber herr stürmer die fragen
nach der impfung mal stellen die sich
hier auch im chat viele stellen denn das
ist natürlich eine große hoffnung und
angela merkel hat gerade noch mal
angesprochen angesprochen sobald die
zulassung da ist die jetzt bis
spätestens ende dieses monats erwartet
wird kann dann auch angefangen werden zu
impfen
benedikt stark über youtube fragt oder
sagt lass doch einfach endlich die
impfung zu wie in großbritannien und den
usa und kuba fragt auch über youtube man
kann die impfung endlich anfangen was
sagen sie dazu
ja es ist natürlich weder ist auch in
deutschland möglich gewesen über eine
sogenannte notfall zulassung den
impfstoff jetzt ein paar tage früher zu
bekommen auf der anderen seite bin ich
immer dass eine notfall zulassung ja
immer den beigeschmack hat dass ihm noch
schneller und unter einem noch größeren
druck erfolgen muss und dementsprechend
bin ich mit dem zulassungsprozess den
wir jetzt hier aktuell auf europäischer
ebene haben diesen sogenannten rollenden
zulassungsprozess wo eben daten
sukzessive eingereicht werden und die
behörden mehrere sachen parallel prüfen
können gar nicht so verkehrt weil wir
werden auch ende diesen jahres eben
unsere zulassung haben in diesen zwei
wochen wird nicht so viel passieren an
impfungen und wir haben auch mehr zeit
letztendlich die logistik vernünftig
aufzubauen und und den feinschliff
herzustellen aber es bringt uns ja
nichts wenn wir jetzt morgen der
zulassung bekommen aber die ganze
logistik noch nicht in der form fertig
gestaltet ist das war wirklich
konsequent und und überall diesen
impfstoff anbieten können und insofern
die zwei wochen die sind denke ich
absolut vertretbar und wir werden dann
entsprechend im neuen jahr auch durch
starten können was das impfen angeht an
der stelle auch noch mal eine oft
gestellte frage und die haben wir beide
sogar auch schon ausführlich miteinander
diskutiert wie sicher ist dieser
impfstoff sollte man sich damit impfen
lassen
ja ich sehe jetzt hier keine probleme
was die sicherheit angeht in der form
dass wir natürlich von sehr vielen
menschen studiendaten gesehen haben
es gibt die klassischen
impfnebenwirkungen die wir von fast
allen impfungen irgendwo kennen die
beschrieben worden sind und die
empfehlung ist ja grundsätzlich immer
sich nicht impfen zu lassen wenn man
gerade in der infekt einen effekt hat
und wenn man das berücksichtigt für sich
selber dann wird man auch denke ich
relativ gut da durchkommen und insgesamt
wenn es wird sich was ganz gravierendes
geben würde was häufig auftritt dann
hätten wir die signale in den studien
schon gesehen insofern gehe ich nicht
davon aus dass wir jetzt irgendwas ganz
gravierendes bekommen würden ganz
ausschließen dass es langzeit
nebenwirkungen oder ganz seltene
nebenwirkungen auch gibt die uns im
nachgang berichtet werden das kann man
natürlich auch zum aktuellen zeitpunkt
nicht stimme ganz kurz nur ein kleiner
ist eine kleine service antwort an die
christen die über youtube fragt es am
mittwoch schule
nein also zumindest nicht in der schule
selbst sondern wahrscheinlich wird es
einen digital unterricht geben es wird
homeschooling geben aber am mittwoch
wird niemand in die schule gehen wenn
wir das alle so richtig verstanden haben
hier nach den maßnahmen sondern bitte zu
hause bleiben und unterricht von zu
hause machen und wir hoffen dass die
digitalisierung und die kultusminister
bis dahin so weit sind dass das auch
klappt fast immer hier kommt noch eine
spezielle frage an sie volker rusty
fragt über youtube professor kekulé
kollege von innen sagt es gibt
verschiedene coronaviren zum beispiel
das wohin virus und das corona typ b
virus aus norditalien gegen welches
helfen die neuen impfstoffe
ja es ist tatsächlich so dass das virus
ja grundsätzlich oder viren
grundsätzlich gerne mutieren und saß
koch 2 macht hier keine ausnahme es gibt
verschiedene stämme inzwischen also die
sich unterschiedlich regional dem
ausgebreitet haben aber von dem was wir
bis jetzt wissen werken wirken die
impfstoffe die gerade in der in studien
sind die in den zulassungsprozess sind
gegen alle diese varianten loch ist
keine variante berichtet worden
dagegen die tatsächlich diese bis dato
entwickelten impfstoffe nicht wirken
werden also da kann ich entwarnung geben
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ich würde gerne
zum ende unseres gesprächs noch mal auf
das eigentliche thema kommen nämlich
weihnachten
eigentlich feiern millionen christen auf
der ganzen welt und auch hier in
deutschland die geburt jesu als
freudenfest als echter liebe als fest
der gemeinsamkeit der erzbischof der
diözese bamberg ludwig schick hat gesagt
lasst die kirchen an weihnachten bitte
trotzdem offen einen lock down der seele
darf es nicht geben wenn wir uns
erinnern alle muslime die das zuckerfest
gefeiert haben in deutschland ende mai
haben auch mit sehr sehr vielen
beschränkungen das gefeiert die moscheen
waren zu man hat mit abstand in der
regel gefeiert vieles hat online
stattgefunden
was würden sie den kirchen empfehlen die
ja noch nicht entschieden haben die
müssen noch abstimmen mit dem
innenministerium was da geht und was
nicht geht in welcher form und in
welcher größe können und sollen in
diesem jahr weihnachtsgottesdienste
stattfinden ja das ist natürlich eine
ganz wichtige frage die natürlich auch
hier mit viel emotionalität behauptet
ist und rein aus wissenschaftlicher
sicht es auch hier auf jeden fall
weniger mehr
es ist absolut notwendig werden
gottesdienste stattfinden eben die
teilnehmerzahlen so zu reduzieren dass
gedränge vermieden wird
dass die masken konsequent getragen wird
oder auch wenn es jetzt für ein
gottesdienst sich komisch anhört ist das
singen in der kirche kontraproduktiv was
eben die verbreitung des virus angeht
es wird sicherlich dann ein sehr
ungewöhnlicher gottesdienst werden und
letztendlich auch jegliche körperliche
berührung und entsprechende nähe sollte
vermieden werden wenn das als
gottesdienst trotzdem stattfinden soll
daneben unter diesen bedingungen dann
ist das risiko deutlich reduziert aber
wie gesagt weniger ist auch in diesem
falle definitiv mehr
vielen dank herr dr stürmer für ihre
einschätzungen bis hierhin und
wahrscheinlich haben noch nie die worte
aus dem lukas evangelium in der neueren
zeit so viel wirkung gehabt wie die der
engel zu den hirten auf dem feld nämlich
fürchtet euch nicht
in diesem sinne vielen dank in allen
auch fürs zuschauen und mitmachen und
ihnen allen noch einen schönen dritten
adventssonntag und eine gute zeit trotz
allem